welcome back to Pittsburgh consensus
live from New York City the first
installment of my explosive World
exclusive interview one of the most
brilliant but controversial artists in
the world yay formerly known as Kanye
West has already hit over a million
views on YouTube he and I went head to
head for two hours yesterday on
everything from anti-Semitism to George
Floyd to White lives matter the tea
study War Kim Kardashian of course his
ex-wife Donald Trump here's a taste of
what's to come in our two-hour special
tomorrow
[Music]
the interview everyone has been waiting
for you're being a Karen
Piers Morgan speaks exclusively to yay
explaining his controversial comments on
George Floyd as the most influential
person on the planet I am questioning it
Kim Kardashian would you like one day to
get back with Kim and his anti-semitic
tweet that got him kicked off Twitter it
is racism when you say I'm going down
no it's not interview adjourned and then
he walks out of the interview
and then he walks back in and apologizes
I will say I'm sorry for the people that
I heard Piers Morgan uncensored
exclusive to our special Friday 8 P.M
and there's a lot more where that came
from it was two of the most
extraordinary hours I've probably ever
had I think as an interviewer uh yay is
no normal interview subject he mocks my
British accent he Delights him being
uncensored and then really tests the
Waters of our lack of censorship
um he's rude about a lot of people he's
warm in past what I didn't expect him to
be it's funny uh he's outrageous he's
shocking he tries to defend the
indefensible but then apologizes for it
so it's a really fascinating watch it'll
be tomorrow night from 8 till 10 on talk
TV Natalie Evans I mean humans Kanye is
now yay everything about him is kind of
fascinating but he's been through a
pretty awful few weeks of saying deeply
inflammatory things about the Jewish
people about George Floyd about white
lives Matter t-shirts enraging Community
after Community what do you think of him
what's going on with him right now
well I think he's clearly a very
confused very vulnerable guy who I mean
as he said in your interview you know he
he has this huge platform you know he's
he's the most influential person in the
world and
perhaps a mental state he's in we all
know he's got you know mental health
issues he denies he has any mental
illness he said that to me he said his
main problem is sleep deprivation which
might well be the case because he's got
one of those I can tell he's got an
incredibly Restless curious fizzing mind
this is why he goes off on tangents all
become very hard to interview yeah but
sort of compelling challenge as well but
I think there's something about his mind
that's just not it's not normal whether
it qualifies as mental illness he says
not well I mean if it's sleep
deprivation there'd be far more of us
running our mouths on on Twitter and our
social media is there any defense for
what some of the stuff he's been saying
I don't think so no I mean it was it was
fascinating to watch your interview that
the clips that we've seen it was quite a
journey with him you know I mean a
fantastic excuse we'd be very proud of
that I know I say but you know for him
to come out you know this this whole
concept of I'm fighting fire with fire
you know it's one thing to you know
stand your ground be be defensive
um but he's also I mean he's like a kid
in the playground that's like oh you
know that guy punched me so I punched
him back it doesn't make it right he can
say he's been the victim of racism that
doesn't mean that he should Target other
groups you know it incites hate in
different directions and as someone with
that profile he shouldn't be doing that
yeah no I think it was interesting
because he he started off wanting to
double down everything and was quite
belligerent and almost sort of offhand
about it but then the longer he studied
he walks off at one stage giving me an
ultimatum he said I'll only apologize
what I said about the Jewish people if
all these business people who've ripped
him off as he says get around a table
and you know apologize to me but he went
away and thought about it and when he
came back he then actually did Issue
quite a sincere apology to any Jewish
people who've been offended by what he
said and said they weren't the target of
his of his anger I think he's got a lot
of pain and anger going on Kanye from
all sorts of different directions his
upbringing the breakup of his marriage
maybe not seeing his kids tonight I
don't know but I gotta say there are
moments of great levity in this
interview he's very entertaining he's
compelling to what and by the end I kind
of felt I I just don't think he's the
Devil he's certainly not the angel you
may want people to think he is
um but interesting what people think
yeah for sure I mean the the kind of it
was fantastic the way you actually did
kind of tease that uh apology out of him
you know he clearly was not looking to
do that and yeah maybe storming off
again I mean but a lot of the parts of
the interview were quite childlike well
it's a bit what he said to me you know
I'm trying to give him advice about if I
were you I think I would think about it
I don't know and then he says um how
rich are you well not as rich as you
obviously is it exactly so what should I
take your advice as if I'm out only
money is the currency for being able to
offer wisdom and I said well why don't
you actually listen to my advice and if
you like what you hear then have nothing
to do with money yeah and then everyone
is perfectly fine to disagree I mean I
completely agree with you he's been
through a lot and he's been through it
yeah on a very very public phone you
know it's no easy thing to go through it
doesn't you know what it doesn't defend
me in defense no no he said some
indefensible things but like I call him
out those and it's an interesting
challenge Natalie thank you very much
indeed good to see you